- [Instructor] What I want
you to do in this video
is a little bit more of a deep dive
into the House of Representatives.
Now we've already talked about how either
chamber of Congress can
introduce general legislation.
And if it gets approved by one chamber,
it has to be voted on and
approved by the other chamber.
But the House of Representatives
has some specific constitutional powers.
So for example, impeachment proceedings
would start in the House
of Representatives.
In other videos we have talked about
impeachment is not the
removal from office,
of say the president, it is
just a formal indictment.
Now if the House of representatives
is able to impeach
someone, say the president,
then it would go to the
Senate to try the impeachment,
to decide whether to
actually convict the person.
Now we've also talked about the House
being the place where tax and
revenue bills would initiate.
So if we're talking about tax or revenue,
these bills would start in
the House of Representatives.
The other areas where the
Senate has more influence
by the Constitution are
in ratifying treaties,
and this is really one
of the significant levers
where the Senate has more
influence on foreign policy,
and also confirmation of
presidential appointments,
either into the executive branch
if we're talking about the cabinet,
or judicial appointments,
the federal court system
including the US Supreme Court.
But beyond these constitutional powers,
there's differences in how
these different houses are run.
And what we'll see is
these processes result
in the Senate being more deliberative.
In the video on filibuster,
we talk about how hard it is
to end the debate in the Senate.
While in the House, the
power is more centralized
amongst not just the majority party,
but amongst the leadership
in that majority party.
We're talking about folks
like the Speaker of the House,
and the inner circle of
the Speaker of the House.
And we'll see why this is in a second.
And to appreciate this centralized power,
and you could argue a more efficient
versus deliberative process in
the House of Representatives,
you just have to remember
that if we have a bill
coming to the House, it will
first go to the Speaker,
who decides which committee it goes to.
So let's say it goes to
some type of a committee right over here.
Now just as in the Senate,
this committee can conduct hearings,
they can have some debate,
and the leadership of
the committee can decide
to bring it to the House floor.
But in reality, what happens is
is that the Rules Committee gets involved.
And as we've talked
about in previous videos,
the Rules Committee in the House
has a significant amount of power.
They can decide, assuming a
bill gets through committee,
they can decide to what degree
it is debated on the House floor.
They can even decide on
the rules of debating.
They could decide on the House floor,
is it going to be debated as the House,
or is it going to be debated
as the Committee of the Whole?
Which happens in the House chamber,
but in this situation,
the House discusses it
as a very, very, very large committee.
And it's usually done for
very important legislation,
or even sometimes complex legislation
where they want to pass it
in a more efficient way.
And so the existence of a
very powerful Rules Committee,
you have a Rules Committee in the Senate,
but they really don't have much power.
But in the House of Representatives,
some would argue that they
are the most important
or most powerful committee,
because they decide how and
when things get debated.
They even decide if there is a debate,
or their amendments can
even be added to bills.
Remember, in our discussion of the Senate,
once something even goes
to the Senate floor,
it's still open to filibuster,
and you still need those 60
votes for closure on a bill.
That is not the case in the
House of Representatives.
Now in theory, there are some mechanisms
where someone could bypass some of this.
So for example,
in a committee in the
House of Representatives,
just as in the Senate,
the leadership of a committee could decide
to not bring something to vote.
They could just put a bill
into limbo, not debate it.
But if someone really wants
it to come to the House floor,
they could use something
called a discharge petition.
Discharge
petition.
But in order to get a discharge petition,
in order to make it successful
so that that bill actually
goes through the House floor
even if the committee chairman
doesn't want it to go there,
it has to get a majority
vote of representatives.
And so you could imagine,
if it's someone from a minority party
trying to have a discharge petition,
it would be very difficult,
because how are they going to get 51%
of the 435 representatives to vote for it.
And so that's why in practice,
this is actually not that typical.
So the big picture here, beyond
the constitutional powers
that are given to the House or the Senate,
in general, the House of Representatives
is much more hierarchical.
The power is centralized,
especially within the majority party.
And because of that centralized power,
it allows the House to get
bills moving much faster,
especially once they go
through the House floor.
You don't have this
notion of a filibuster,
and this notion that you
have to get a super majority
in order to actually get a
vote and get something passed.